hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode one through
three video just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen any of the season 2
episodes yet I'm mostly going to be
doing Easter eggs and kind of explaining
how this fits into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one of the big differences from
season 2 is that it's actually doing a
lot more stuff from the comics than it
is from the movies so because I'm
probably not going to be able to do
videos for every single episode I'll
explain the biggest stuff first so first
big WTF the black goo that they're
calling zero point matter on the show is
the dark force which is actually
something from the Doctor Strange comics
so you could say that this is more
connected to dr. strange things like the
Doctor Strange movie then the Captain
America movies which is kind of funny
because season 1 was all about Captain
America but I think it's actually a
really good thing for them to get out
from under the Captain America movie
shado
it's just that all the big moments that
people remember involving Peggy involve
Captain America so automatically
everyone's mind goes to that when you
mentioned Peggy Carter coming forward to
episodes 2 & 3 you see that Whitney
Frost
aka Madame masque is infused with the
dark force in the dark force is actually
an energy that can be manipulated by
people that are attuned to it there are
other characters in the comics that are
able to use it
cloak is one example that Dark Hawk
quagmire there's even a twist on it the
DC Comics has it's basically extra
dimensional energy that has a level of
sentience like it's it's implied that
it's alive but think of it in the way
you would think about them trying to
harness the power of the tesseract in
the movies
limitless power but it's not the exact
same thing like the the dark force power
is not the same type of power is the
tesseract energy agents of shield also
did a version of dark force in season 1
in an episode called Providence it was
like season 1 episode 18 they did The
Blackout character he is able to access
the dark force the way you see Whitney
Frost using the power in episode 3 is
way cooler if you're confused about how
Whitney Frost killed her director
essentially what the dark force lets you
do is absorb all forms of energy and her
using the power was more reactive so
she's probably going to learn to control
it over the next couple of episodes the
next big thing Whitney Frost the Madame
masque character they already they
announced they were doing her character
she's probably like the biggest
comic-book character they brought on the
show and she's not going to be wearing
the mask
anytime soon but maybe by the end of the
series Madame masque is actually
appeared in the invincible Iron Man if
you started reading that recently the
Madame masque character teased that up
so I'm hoping that the scar on her face
like the dark force scar is going to get
bigger and she will be forced to wear
the mask just to hide it from everyone
next big WTF the arena club in the
Council of nine I know everybody's
wondering this symbol looks exactly like
the symbol of the organization that
predated Hydra that agents of shield has
been doing this year so just careful for
spoilers from agents of shield I have to
explain that a little bit so when agents
of shield this year they did this really
interesting thing with Hydra because
Hydra is such a big organization from
the comics that the movies have
explained so they're always gonna keep
going back to that well but in order to
deepen the mythology which I'm really
happy that they did they present Hydra
is the most recent iteration of this
ancient organization tied to the
Inhumans now the thing about agent
Carter is that this pin yes the symbol
looks very similar but what the
producers of agent Carter have said is
that it has nothing to do with the
agents of shield Hydra organization they
said that it's tied to the secret Empire
from the comics which is a completely
different evil group of people so the
secret Empire was created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby in the mid-60s to be this
general terrorist organization that was
not Hydra they had already created Hydra
so they wanted another organization to
go to so they were just like this
mystery council of really powerful
people acting behind the scenes their
first appearance was actually during a
Bruce Banner or Hulk storyline so I'm
not expecting any Hydra references from
any of this council of nine stuff an
agent Carter I think it's going to be
its own separate thing they might pay
reference to some things that are going
on with Hydra but at this point in
history Hydra is still kind of baking in
the oven if you remember way back to the
agent Carter finale from season one they
tease the beginning of Hydra they
captured all the Nazi scientists and
they were gonna start working for the US
government but they were all secretly
going to get together to form Hydra
moving on to Howard Stark things always
a lot of fun to see Dominic Cooper show
up he is operating a movie studio as of
starkwood it totally makes sense that he
has business interests all over the
world so really you could do almost any
kind of story with him anywhere in the
world and it would be plausible like oh
of course
she has this secret research base in
Switzerland oh of course he has people
working in Brazil of course he has this
giant movie studio with all these piays
walking around that he's trying to have
sex with I like the way they tease
Howard you know he's helping Peggy
figure out what's going on with the dark
forest using his science but they also
buried the lede a little bit he's also
trying to revolutionize the motion
picture industry in the way film is
exposed
he's like I'm working on a silver
nitrate solution that will allow me to
show the entire visible spectrum and
every once in a while one of the
characters will make a turn of phrase
that'll be a reference to something from
the movies so you really do have to
listen carefully like you might have to
watch the episode a couple times but the
biggest one in Episode three like
recently was Jarvis making a reference
about never wanting to be a floaty head
voice because they create this home
alarm where Jarvis's voice is like
you're in the wrong area you're not
supposed to be here
oh I never want to be a disembodied
voice you know cut to the Iron Man
movies when Tony Stark has used Jarvis's
voice to create his AI it's been a while
since I've talked about this because
there's a different version of the
Jarvis character in the movies in the
comics in an agent Carter so just to
explain what's going on with Jarvis the
voice and Jarvis the AI that becomes the
vision character so Jarvis was an actual
person that worked for Howard Stark he
became a caretaker for Tony Stark
whenever Howard was away like all Marvel
superheroes he has crazy daddy issues
because his dad wasn't around all the
time
so Jarvis was kind of like a parent to
him in the way that Alfred is apparent
to Bruce Wayne so in the context of the
movie universe when Jarvis died Tony
Stark turned him into an AI just because
that's his sense of humor
so eventually Jarvis becomes the basis
for vision Jarvis becomes the vision
even though it's not completely Jarvis
vision is the baby of Ultron the mind
gem in Jarvis so he has aspects of all
those things inside of him so we go from
this to this but if you're also reading
the comics in the all new Avengers the
Kamala Kahn Avengers I'll just I'll call
it that a version of Jarvis is still
alive and serves Tony Stark so it's it's
kind of this funny story where he shows
up at the New Avengers facility which is
this rundown plane hangar but this
season so far
Asia Carter has been
is a great TV series I feel like
sometimes it's a hard sell if you don't
like period shows like it like if you
don't want to watch something that takes
place during the 40s and 50s so let me
know what do you guys think of agent
Carter so far this season I feel like
it's a lot of fun I feel like it's
having a little bit more fun that it
didn't season one and it's moving a
little bit quicker I like that they're
doing more comic-book things like I said
though I might not have time to do
videos for every single episode so if I
miss a video next week I'll just do a
video later for all the stuff that I
missed because it's actually a really
good show but for those that are asking
agents of shield will come back after
agent Carter's run is over but in
slightly related news if you guys didn't
know tonight arrow is gonna be a lot of
fun Felicity is gonna take a whole bunch
of drugs it is gonna be the most fun
thing ever I always love it when
characters get super high and do really
crazy stuff legends of tomorrow episode
2 is on Thursday as well so lots of DC
lots of Marvel stuff happening I'm gonna
circle back around there's some new
Captain America spider-man stuff
happening I'm gonna do a video for in
the next couple days too so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if
there's any Marvel stuff you guys want
just let me know in the comments below
just in case you guys haven't seen it
last night was probably one of the best
episodes of the flash season 2 you can
click here it's my episode 11 video and
you can click here for all my other
Captain America Civil War videos thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you